[Music]
can I just say you don't have to be at
the Met to turn out a look I mean my
goodness yeah I guess I'm only competing
with Lionel and Luke
thank God okay but there wasn't a hot
jacket that we liked that Luke was
wearing now is that the ultimate prize
for winning the judge's song contest
this jacket hi Dad I want it
I mean I said it in just but I mean it
because my dad texted me twice
so I hope he does well you get that
jacket also bragging rights and also you
must be proud because those contestants
know how to pick a right song huh well I
mean I didn't win by a lay on slide
let's be honest and I think that that is
actually what makes the show like a lot
um we agree a lot Luke Lionel and myself
and you know we are that team
um but I like to push these contestants
outside of their comfort zone and just
break that box yeah well Luke and Lionel
I know you also huddled right when when
you decided to save Oliver what was
about him that you're like we gotta see
more
I mean I think you know there are a
couple of people that may be in the same
genre and so I think it's really at this
point about
narrowing down people to their own lanes
and their own instant identity and look
Mary Beth bird and Tyson they came so
far especially tonight like what they
gave us tonight was beyond what they've
ever given us and so I hope I think that
was the gift for them they got there
right there's so many standing ovations
well deserved okay next week we have Ed
Sheeran and Alanis Morissette filling in
as guest judges now did you get a say
because I know you have said that jag
little pill changed your life I'm just
so happy it's Alanis and Ed because I'm
a fan of both but um it'll be exciting
to hear what they actually have to say
and how they you know constructively
critique if they have to
um but it was funny the reaction from
the kids when they heard Ed Sheeran I
was like well should we go away more
often like Lionel did say you got a
little nervous when you heard the names
and saw the reaction I saw Katie Katie
got kind of worried she said well wait I
said Katie is just basement for one
night don't get nervous just one week
it's just one week well we're we're
going to be hanging with the king so
um you guys will still be checking in
right next week while you're in the UK
we still have a job to do on American
Idol that's right so we will be tuning
in from Windsor Castle
foreign